zehn minuten ist das ganze dorf techart
mehr auf den beinen
mit den wasserschläuchen die hänge
hinauf den flammen entgegen die talwärts
rasen mit allen mitteln versuchen sie
ihre häuser und habe zu retten in der
glühenden hitze die das wasser
verdunsten lässt sobald es den boden
erreicht und wenn auch die olivenzweigen
nichts mehr ausrichten können gegen die
glutnester bleibt am schluss nur die
flucht hinunter zum meer wo sie
vielleicht sicher sind vor den flammen
mit den tieren die halb verrückt vor
angst sind und kaum luft bekommen
ich bin am ende unsere häuser brennen
unser wald brennt und wir können nichts
tun unter staat kümmert sich nicht wenn
wir uns nicht selbst helfen würden wäre
alles verloren
es gibt nicht genug feuerwehrleute keine
hubschrauber keine flugzeuge ein
flugzeug für den präsidenten stand
freilich bereit als er sich die brände
aus der luft an schaute um schnell zu
verkünden alles sei unter kontrolle und
niemand müsse leiden
diese parolen klingen zunehmend hohe
weil die feuer weiter wüten und für die
teebeutel die er den feuer geplagten
volk zu war wurde ihm auch nicht
überschwänglich gedankt aber dass ihre
löschflugzeuge nicht einsatzbereit waren
und andere staaten aushelfen mussten
daran werden sich viele türken erinnern
bodrum antalya marmaris es sind die
schönsten küstenabschnitte im griff der
verheerendsten brände seit
menschengedenken ein dorf nach dem
anderen muss geräumt werden und der
korona geschädigte tourismus erleidet
einen weiteren schweren rückschlag
es kam ganz plötzlich wir haben gar
nicht verstanden wie das passieren
konnte
immer neue feuerwachen die heißen winde
an die finden immer neue nahrung um die
grünen hügel in traurigem und
landschaften zu verwandeln und gewaltige
rauchschwaden spannen einen trüben
schleier der hunderte kilometer über das
mittelmeer zieht und sich vielleicht
irgendwo vereint mit den brandwolken aus
sizilien die feriensaison ist jetzt
schon zu ende im strandbad lecker panini
bei catania die menschen sind im
schatten des feuerspuckenden etwa an
alarm und brandgefahr gewöhnt aber so
etwas hat hier noch keiner erlebt am
stadtrand wo die ausgedörrten wälder bis
an die siedlung reichen blieb vielen
einwohnern nur noch die flucht
überall im umland treibt der trocken
heiße scirocco wind die feuer vor sich
her dutzende wurden am wochenende
gezählt die lösch teams waren tag und
nacht im einsatz
aber dann kam zumindest in den
höhenlagen das wetter zur hilfe und nun
hängen nicht brandwolken sondern
nebelschwaden über dem dorf piana delhi
alberne sie eine autostunde südlich von
palermo und dem gestüt von giuseppe di
pisa
das feuer kam von da drüben und es war
unglaublich schnell
und um ein haar hätte es die beide
erreicht wo meine pferde standen 28
tiere hatte er hier die er alle in
sicherheit bringen konnte
bevor die hubschrauber der feuerwehr das
inferno beendeten jetzt schreitet er
seine weidezäune ab und finanziert den
schaden die elektro drähte sind verglüht
die wasserpumpen zerschmolzen und von
den autos ist auch nichts brauchbares
mehr übrig im grunde hatte ich noch
glück denn ich habe nur sachschäden bei
meinen nachbarn sind tiere erschreckt
was für ein schrecklicher tod auf den
vielen brachflächen ringsherum liege zu
viel totholz und gestrüpp sagt er
die bauern müssten besser auf ihr land
aufpassen manche vermuten auch dass
mitarbeiter der wald aufsicht die brände
gelegt haben könnten sie werden nur
bezahlt wenn sie im einsatz sind das
passiere auf sizilien laut aussprechen
will das aber keiner
in athen sprechen alle nur über ein
thema das wetter seit 30 jahren haben
sie eine solche gluthitze nicht mehr
erlebt tagsüber geht sie nicht unter 40
grad
wegen der vielen klimaanlagen wird sogar
der baldige kollaps des stromnetzes
befürchtet denn auch für den rest der
woche machen die meteorologen keine
hoffnung auf abfindung und dann
dienstagabend am grünen stadtrand das
wohl unausweichliche wie es begann kann
noch niemand mit gewissheit sagen nur
dass vier gemeinden die im norden der
hauptstadt an die pinienwälder grenzen
hals über kopf evakuiert werden mussten
das rettete viele menschen leben aber 80
häuser gingen in der nacht verloren und
als die athener mit beißenden
brandgeruch in der nase und zum dröhnen
der löschflugzeuge erwachten kamen die
ersten hausbesitzer zurück um rauchende
ruine und vorzufinden schreinermeister
manolis hat die nacht auf der straße
verbracht jetzt findet der haus und
werkstatt zerstört gestern abend bin ich
mit dem renovieren fertig geworden ich
hatte gar keine zeit es zu genießen
und während sie in der hauptstadt die
letzten brandnester löschen beklagt 200
kilometer westlich von evan bauer ja
nissen jannis den verlust eines ganzen
arbeitslebens sein dörfchen sie ja
malerischen die grünen oliven einige
tupft hat schon am wochenende gebrannt
20 häuser sind hier zerstört auch herrn
jannis weinstöcke und sein ganzer stolz
die olivenbäume über 70 jahre standen
manche die meisten hat er selbst
gepflanzt
die waren die kinder für mich das waren
die mühen eines ganzen lebens
das macht man nicht nebenbei dafür muss
man kämpfen dieser kampf scheint nun
erst einmal verloren